I don't know why what you were just this
is a therapy session I'm baring it all
it's like more information that anybody
ever wanted the new song the new video
is out now it's called so good
yes how are you feeling now that it's
out in the universe I'm actually feeling
I'm feeling great I'm doing my best not
to say I feel so good I'm really happy I
think I have like it's a mulches
relationship with my job sometimes why I
just dive right in I'm like let's go get
a period no but you know I just think
that like I was actually just texting my
agent and I was like because I I was um
this was very much the kind of thing
that happened naturally like I found
cupid through actually something he did
with Laura Harrier for V Magazine and I
saw that and I was like how did they do
that and then I was like you know
incredible visual was done by cupid's
fault and I messaged him and I was like
I'm obsessed with you can you come and
do something with me and then at the
same time my texts my labels like I'm
obsessed with this guy can we find a way
to work with him and then it just like
evolved from there and and and it became
something really like organic and
natural which is something that's so
nice about music is it can really be it
like motivated by the artist yeah and
Cupid is just so talented and the whole
team that made the video happen is so
talented and it's so cool to be like
this is me it's like the same thing is
like posting like a diary entry or
something it's much more creative than
than some other stuff that we usually do
because it sounds like you're in a
really so good side life right now you
know I actually I am in a good place
right now I've it's difficult isn't it I
mean I think like as any human alive in
the world and especially as like I know
you know anybody in the industry I think
is usually like a sensitive I mean
there's everybody's I would say to some
degree sensitive but I think like as
artists where especially can be more
sensitive so my my phases of you know
being good and being bad or very Evan
flow like I can be like absolutely
stable phenomenal wonderful for like
weeks and be like wow this is it I'm
tapped in this is who I am and then just
like drop
and it can happen with no warning and
you know that's I think that's what life
looks like these days I think that's
also just like how I'm wired but but I
do I would say overall right now I am I
am really good and I think that a lot of
that has to do with with music and sort
of stepping into my own as a creative
and stepping into my own as somebody who
who calls shots and as well I think you
call a shot or two and then people say
admit it works out and then you go oh
that really worked out I'm gonna do that
again and then you just kind of build
this relationship of like trust with
yourself and and then you become more
creative and it really like feeds into
developing you as a person that yeah did
Thomas it all inspire so good cuz
there's a part of the beginning where it
sounds like maybe he did you know what
he didn't he didn't just has nothing to
do with so good and if you listen it's
more of a celebration of an end of a
relationship okay and this is the ex
maybe that were I you know we all have
exes a relatable subject I mean I do
love the lyric maybe I just woke up on
the right side of my empty bed
[Music]
or I'm not sad when I'm watching him
leave right you know because I I've said
very publicly I do not like a breakup
song my last single one of my last
singles bloodshot I think was very
everybody commonly kind of thought it
was a breakup song when it was much more
of a song about loss yeah which is a
common theme in my life and the lives
around me and if he wasn't to it through
that lens I think it's much more clear
that that's what it's about
but it's so good is also gonna break up
song it's a song about a girl who is
turning a page and he's not sad about it
I've definitely been there when it was a
good thing that something ended
everybody gets at least one yeah I want
to play you a clip really fast
mm-hmm you guys are obviously very young
but it's she the one like do you talk
about that yeah yeah wait that's yours
lighting up so perfect I'm so much it's
adorable y'all know of course I mean she
is just the most incredible person I've
ever met
thank you so I mean I think people see
her as so talented because obviously
that's how she that's her job to perform
and to all the rest of it but she so
she's most compassionate and most
patient and most like genuine loving
person I've ever met and it's so kind
and so generous like she's just amazing
how does that feel to watch that you
know it's funny I actually have you
teary-eyed mmm-hmm yeah yeah I'm just
super emotional embarrassing but like I
cry over death limbs yeah I cry every
day when I'm with him because he's just
so really close I could see him being
zapped you know I'm being sappy and this
is like um embarrassing
he's such a I mean like I felt this way
when I met him he's just like the most
pure loving selfless generous kind like
his his life is about the people that he
loves and I feel so lucky to be loved by
somebody like that you know cuz I'd like
I think I I told him like the first
couple months we were dating I was like
I I had this big breakdown I don't know
why we were just this is a therapy
session I'm baring it
like more information that anybody ever
wanted but I know I love all this this
is I had a like a breakdown I visited
him in London I think for the first time
when we were dating but we weren't
officially boyfriend-girlfriend we were
just dating and I like randomly I mean
this is the story of my life but I was
like in a great mood and then like we
made eye contact and I burst into tears
and and he was like what is going on
with you
and I was like I just don't think I ever
thought that I would have the privilege
to to be so like seen by somebody like I
always I always know this is stupid
I always told my mom when I was little
like I think I'm gonna be like alone for
like my life because I never thought
that anybody would quite understand me
or like I knew I could be people read me
wrong even when I was little I'm so
meeting Thomas and having him just like
understand me from the get-go it was
like we met and it was like oh there you
are
and so you know I just I just feel lucky
and I know there were three years in but
like it just feels so I feels like was
every day you know people strive to have
that kind of relationship
so it feels very lucky yeah it feels
very I mean like you know we also have
to work at it long distance is hard
we're constantly I mean we're not always
together we do make it work like we fly
out to see each other and stuff like
that all the time even just for like a
few days but I think it really just
comes down to the fact that we're we're
we're like givers both of us are the
giver in the relationship which usually
there's a giver and a taker mm-hmm and I
think because we're both givers to our
other half and we're also best friends
it just happens to be the most like
healthy you know wonderful not kids you
know we've all been there we've all been
in relationships that we're not healthy
and it like took from us and then it's
it just feels like we both overflow for
each other in terms of like relationship
energy and that's lucky you agree with
him that he's the he's on yeah one is an
engagement happening I mean listen I've
come back and forth I'm like whether or
not that's like even a thing I want to
do but like I think yeah and I
definitely think I definitely think um
you know
if I'm gonna marry anyone it's gonna be
hell yeah you mentioned the ebbs and the
flows of this industry what sort of
things trigger you to be up here and
then maybe to sort of crash and go a
little bit oh if I knew that I would
have a lot more worked out than I do I
mean things that trigger like highs and
me are usually oh it's it's hard to say
because sometimes it's almost always
accidental because if I knew how to work
myself that well I think I would
probably try to stay there more but I
would say like things that trigger highs
or like self-care yeah you know quiet
time definitely social media makes me so
anxious because I have I have really bad
anxiety and terrible anxiety I'm
surprised by that for some ways
unbelievable anxiety but I think that I
think that I've just learned to I don't
know I think when you have anxiety and
then you're in situations where you have
to power through like you've got to go
on camera right now or like you know you
have to get up on a stage right now I
think for better or for worse I've
learned to kind of make it disappear I
still feel it but you maybe not you
maybe don't see it right but I would say
that things that trigger highs for me
like like stability would be would be
stability like um routine time away from
my phone and and like simple health
things like as I get older I realize
like I need to sleep I need to drink
water I need to be good to myself I used
to be really I think like not take
myself seriously as like a mammal you
know I'd be like I just gonna power
through I mean I have like nine ventis
and I'm not gonna sleep and I just make
it work and and I never I didn't really
take my health seriously but I do know
and and that helps and and like little
things like sometimes if I'm not good
I'll like go out and get a tattoo or
something out how many tattoos do you
have now I have nine big nine okay
but I was where Thomas and I were
supposed to get our tenth today together
like a matching not matching we have a
matching one my second my third tattoo I
ever got is a matching tattoo with
Thomas that's what is it son it's this
little son I have on my finger
I'm like trying to like get in the zoo
me yeah and he has a massive one on his
knee and we got it like it a terrible
like it was like we've met like a month
before that or something or two we I
don't remember the timeline of it but it
was like we weren't dating yet and you
just decided let that permanent ink
I wasn't even so much that it was more
like we're both such emotional people
and such like you know spontaneous
people and we were falling in love and
it was like even if this goes totally
south you know like yeah that's it what
has just do it yeah so so we did and
it's it's romantic I love that I have to
know go back to the video how long did
the process take to get all the florals
and flowers and all that on you you know
it's um I wouldn't say more than like a
normal makeup change would take I was
wearing basically no makeup makeup like
I think Cupid put like some foundation
like a little bit of like spongy and
then you could see like a tiny bit of
mascara but no falsies no there was
anything like red eyeshadow at one point
for one look but that was it um a little
bit of eyeshadow on the lip but like
kind of basically out of minutes for him
I think where I usually think this was
like two hours but it was nice because
first of all it's just so incredible to
watch him work because what he does is
he gets bouquets from like I think a
grocery store and he just showed up with
a like maybe two bouquets and he just
cuts them and then starts to frame the
face in really creative ways and it was
nice for me as well because I I have a
bit of like because I am so anxious I
have a bit of a fear of like being
vulnerable in the industry like I get
very like like I need to put up some
some kind of wall some kind of barrier
because it can feel very invasive um
sometimes just you know that's kind of
the nature of it it's if you don't
people don't realize that no they think
that you must have it all together what
is your message to your young fans who
think that you have it
you do it all you don't struggle over
anything Wow it's that's difficult to
answer because if I was to say a message
I would want to say something
inspirational and informative and like
you know if I'm if I was to give a
message to young fans I wouldn't want it
to be like I'm struggling like I would
wanted write something that would help
them but I mean I don't know I am in the
camp of believing that mental health I
think the best way that I can be a
mental health advocate so far yeah I'm
not going to say that I couldn't get
better about it or I couldn't learn more
but it's just to be honest about where
I'm at with my own mental health which
is ever ever changing and and always
evolving and I mean I guess if I was to
give a message it's that I think it
would be helpful to remember that there
is nobody in the world that ever has it
all together no matter how much they
look like they do I definitely I mean I
guess I I get surprised by how often
people think I have it all together
because I consider myself to be someone
who's really open about what I struggle
with what my life looks like but you
know I also do know that like social
media is fleeting you see one thing you
see another thing and then you see one
post about like I talked about my dad
and then it'll be like nine posts of
like really glossy selfies and you
forget you know you forget that people
are human and and it's not just me it's
I I don't know almost anybody that is
like I'm great I have it all together
but I also I can understand why it why
it might feel like that and look like
that and whatever you feel I can
guarantee you there are so many other
people who feel that exact same thing
and we all need to remember that that
kindness like I know that it's so like
everybody's like be nice maybe hear it
every day and we're like okay but it's
so important especially now we were just
talking before we started filming it
like the the the kind of like the need
to bring others down has become so
prevalent and it will never ever help
you feel better there's what is that
saying where it's like I'm not gonna get
this right and people are gonna get mad
at me but there's like while you're
waiting for the
to throw a hot coal you burn your own
hand it's that's not good to me any yeah
it's not that but any any kind of like
negative something you feel is actually
not a reflection of the person that you
feel it towards that the reflection of
you and so I would recommend like
looking inward at why you feel that way
and and that's more of a marker to pay
attention to yourself and what you're
dealing with then then maybe what the
other person is triggering in you right
which isn't to say that it's okay to
like unknowingly trigger other people
it's it's just that you know it might be
it might be worth it might be more worth
your time to look inside yourself to
realize what's happening rather than
focusing on what that person is doing
and yeah and I mean I definitely I
definitely struggle with the whole
gambit of it so it's nice to remember
that that no matter how perfect
somebody's life looks it's that's not
what it looks like we're all human at
the end of the day yeah exactly
you've been talking about prioritizing
music for a very long time yeah is there
an album one way you know what that's so
funny I feel like I can answer every
question about music except for that one
because I don't know I mean I have
enough songs at this point that I could
do an album but it's interesting the way
that people consume music these days
isn't really alcohol them eccentric and
that's what's so interesting to me
because my fans are always saying like
where's the album where's the album and
and while I'm sure that like if I was a
fan of somebody I would buy their album
but like in terms of people who aren't
my fans I don't think that an album is
the smartest choice I don't think that
it's the way that people are buying
these days streaming and I think that
what is sort of more current and the way
that I consume music is singles videos
so I think that's kind of the current
plan but that's not to say that there is
no album in the works I have so many
songs that I love that I've done that
are like ready to go they don't have
videos yet and when they do I'm sure
that I'll be putting them out really
consistently but I also have I just got
out of the studio recording like six new
songs so like I don't know I mean it's
it's really interesting I always thought
music was really planned and it's very
spur-of-the-moment so I'll keep you
posted okay it's just kind of like it's
like it's a do as you go thing but you
think a next single is coming
rather than later oh yes the video gets
done oh yeah I have like content on
content don't come back okay we need to
drop this right now are you someone
who's constantly writing like I know
that you wrote this song with Julia and
you just I'm a trans Turner which
they're an amazing duo I know are you
always writing are you always looking
for inspiration yeah I mean I think that
like I think I my mom's a writer and I
have always written poetry and songs and
things like that and I'm always writing
like I post a lot of like journal
entries or like you know like I'll think
about a topic and I'll expand on and do
like mini essays and things like that I
used to do that more but I'm always I'm
always thinking I'm a communicator by
nature and so I get like little tidbits
of like it's interesting I don't I'm not
like a melody person this is my one
thing as a writer where I don't get
melodies in my head and I think it's
because I am so auditory that if I get a
melody in my head it's something that
already exists mm and so I'm much more
of a lyricist
Wow they are the best part of a song to
me really I think it's it's a it's a if
they've got to be right together yeah
but i do i always get little like
snapshots or tidbits or like ideas or
something will like float into my brain
and i'm like that's a great lyric or
that's a great concept or title or
something like that so yeah what does
this mean for acting like are you a
hundred percent focused on singing and
music right now no I actually I just got
it I actually just got a phone call
two nights ago that my next movie is
moving forward is it wicked it's not
working
that'd be amazing no I can't I can't say
too much about it right now but I'm
really happy about it because I've
mostly been doing I like my my dream is
that I constantly switch back and forth
between like movies TV music and stage
and if I ever do something repetitively
for too long I get like really itchy
okay um so I'm like I'm really ready for
this new era of like film and music
those two things for me go together yeah
really well yeah will it be in the
Disney family or something a little
different you know there are two and one
is not
what one is more in the Disney family
than the other but it's not a Disney
Channel venture okay Disney plus I can't
say okay I can't say but the I tried I'm
sorry I wish I could say but the other
one is no it's it's very far from
anything and it isn't family yeah
is it kind of nice to sort of explore
like a more mature path you know it's so
funny it's this dislike last couple
months has been so focused on like me
leaving Disney and graduating and what's
gonna happen and like kind of like a
subtext of like what am I gonna lose my
mind and I just feel nothing about that
like I feel it was such a wonderful time
in my life when I was on Disney and it's
been such an easy transition and Disney
really has been so like nurturing I
never felt that kind of like I was in a
pressure box like I was never like get
me out and so when it ended it was much
more like wow I never realized how much
it I keep saying this and I look for I
keep looking for a better way to say it
but it's like when you leave your
parents house to go to college it's like
I didn't realize how much of me and what
I was doing and putting out there was
affected by where I was because it just
felt so natural and normal and I didn't
really think about it um and now I'm I
feel really like naturally stepping into
this new era for myself and I also feel
really like supported by the people
around me it's very much like no one's
like what are you doing like stop you
know getting tattoos and stop swearing
in your songs it's very like it's it
just seems like a natural transition and
so I I don't really feel a pressure to
change that or like I'm like looking for
more mature roles or substance or like
anything like that I just feel like it's
not really happening sure yeah so it
just feels it feels good but it felt
good then too you know yeah I feel at
peace
is there a dream role for you that you
would love to play hide from wicked well
gelinda was always my dream growing up
and so I'm very pleased that it hasn't
happened yet because I'm like I feel
like I'm like at the right age like
that's gonna happen soon because I
talked to Kristen Chenoweth and she
really wants you and ariana grande
together and that move
that would be the dream yeah how you and
Ari talked about it yeah I mean yeah I
mean like you know I think that it's
much less official than it sounds like I
think that like I mean it's not official
at all but I just mean like I think that
we're like if Ari and I have talked
about it it's just more like on like a
girlish like you would like to do it
yeah we're friends so it's like it's
more like Oh wouldn't that be so cool
like did you see Kristin posted you know
like it's that kind of thing it's not
like yeah meet you on Wednesday you know
it's nothing like that
and I have tiles so I don't have
anything to do with the movie at all
I just feel very lucky to be part of the
conversation I feel like the Dove Empire
is expanding you have the new sunglass
oh yeah how did that yeah how'd that
come about that was actually something
that came about totally randomly they
contacted me and they said would you be
interested in designing a capsule
collection and my parents were designers
they were jewelry designers and so I was
always on the you know the design room
floor when they would sketch things and
then they would get it back and I would
see things come from paper to reality
and that was always something really
interesting to me I thought when I was
younger I wanted to design clothing
because of that but you know I've always
had an eye for not like an eye like a
talent but I've always had like an
obsession with design and I usually look
at things that other people have
designed of this is terrible I don't
mean this critically I just like if I
were to wear this I wish it was more
like this you know like I I think it
would be better if it was like that like
I just have always found myself to be
someone that had a lot of opinions about
clothing and about styling and and I'm a
big sunglasses fan and so I was excited
yeah I was geeky and excited about it to
see what was gonna happen but I was
scared that they were gonna design them
for me and just put my name on it huh
but you got to be involved oh no I did
everything are using absolutely amazing
were you sketching no my sketching would
literally look I'd be like stir it all
yeah cool fellas it's like I'm not I
can't draw to save my life say but I I
would grab I would grab like sample
frames and then I'd be like I wanted
this shape I wanted this color and they
would send me samples back and I would
make like such control freaky notes I'd
be like one centimeter whiter the bridge
is to cleave it to be like you know
light or this I was so controlled freaky
that's so funny but then it ends up
being exactly what you want that's so
fun yeah
is there a world where there's a
clothing line maybe maybe one day I just
wouldn't want to do something where I
only took like twenty percent pardon and
that's why I'm really one of those
people that unless I can do it all the
way I don't want to do it at all
anything that's part of my anxieties I
like I love to do things when I'm like
not ready all the time and then I'm like
I hate this I don't want to do this then
but I think I definitely if I was to do
it I'd have to be like this is done this
is done everybody go away house lockdown
I'm doing this 100% and I don't know if
I have that time right now sure but like
one day in my life that be such a fun
thing yeah I think well your red carpet
looks lately have been so OnPoint thank
you how involved are you and picking out
what you're gonna wear
well you know what I have this
incredible stylist Mimi katrell
shoutout to Mimi who is super talented
and she definitely I think she's really
good at like whatever her client is at
the moment like reading them and then
elevating them and so you know she picks
things but then you as the client you
step it in you you you it comes down to
you actually you know at the very end so
yeah I'm very involved as well like we
have like a text chain that I'm always
like screenshot I love this you know
next week I want to wear this or this
actually I just this I just I told
myself but usually she Styles all the
carpet looks yeah I think that she's
them yeah it definitely it definitely
feels like a new a new era for me I love
that that's fun um we're gonna wrap up
so we tell fans where they can watch the
video where they can stream the song
yeah you can
you can stream or purchase the song on
any and all music platforms and my video
for so good is available on my VEVO
channel and it's also in the link in my
bio on my Instagram I think if you just
go to my Instagram on my Twitter pretty
easy to find and also check out my new
capsule collection with Prive Revo
[Music]